this week marks one year since the
passage of the tax cuts and Jobs Act the
legislation reduced tax rates for
individuals and increase the standard
deduction it also cut the corporate tax
rate from thirty five percent to twenty
one percent since the tax cuts took
effect this year they have been credited
with boosting the economy but they've
also been criticized for not helping
working families as part of our series
issues that matter we're taking a closer
look at the impact of those tax cuts and
the state of the economy
one year later Gary cone served as
director of the National Economic
Council and as chief economic advisor to
President Trump during the tax debate he
resigned from his White House post in
March and he joins us for an interview
you'll see only on CBS this morning good
morning great to have you at the table
thanks for having me it's great to be
here let's start with the economy the SP
is at a 14-month low we continue to see
these wild markets sell offs former Fed
Chairman Janet Yellen says she's really
concerned about another financial crisis
because of too much deregulation and
corporate borrowing is she wrong let's
start with the US economy because that's
really what's core to everything the US
economy is really strong right now we're
gonna have 3.3 percent GDP growth in the
United States this year we have jobs or
unemployment at all-time
well not all-time 50-year low right now
we've got a three point seven percent
unemployment rate in the United States
we have wages growing at 3.1 percent but
the more interesting part about the wage
growth is that we've got the bottom end
of workers the lower paid workers
growing at a faster rate than the higher
paid worker and we think that's directly
attributable to the tax bill if you look
at what's going on with corporate
spending we're starting to see corporate
spending come back into the system which
is exactly what we hit rejected when we
passed the tax bill
we gave companies a five-year window to
expense all of their capital capital
expenditures we've seen in recent weeks
we've seen companies like Apple and
Amazon announced mega billion-dollar
plants where they're gonna really go out
and build new plants hire new people
that is gonna start hitting the economy
in the beginning of next year and we
think we're gonna see a lot more of that
in the next couple years so we think the
fundamental economy
in the united states is very strong
we've yet to see corporate impact at
corporate spending really make an impact
as far as the gdp overall we anticipated
a sugar rush immediately following the
tax cut you were really selling this as
a way in a mechanism for companies to
reinvest in the economy i want to play
back a clip of you last year talking to
a group of CEOs about this can i ask you
all a quick question
if the tax reform bill goes through do
you plan to increase investment of your
company's investment capital investment
just a show of hands the tax reform goes
through okay why aren't the other hands
up so the ceos were really precious wild
we did see some reinvestment most of it
was seen in stock buyback and dividends
so are you not disappointed in the
results no if you actually look at the
numbers we're seeing exactly what we
would have thought we would have seen in
capital expenditures small and
medium-sized businesses are spending
because if you think of a smaller
medium-sized business today the the
regulatory process that they need to go
through to spend is not that difficult
if you're a sole proprietor that owns a
pizza restaurant or owns a nail salon or
the dry cleaner and you want to expand
to a second store you really just have
to go out and lease the store and buy
the equipment and hire a few people if
you're going out to build a huge
manufacturing facility in the united
states is that's gonna hire fifteen
twenty thirty thousand people you need
to go out and do a massive plan for that
you need to go out and acquire the land
you need to get the permits you need to
hire the architects you need to go
through that entire process takes well
over a year when we did our tax plan
which was based on a ten year cycle we
assumed that we get no major capex in
the first year on stock repurchases it
makes enormous a lot of sense for
companies to repurchase our stock now
especially she said stocks are low you
look at the dividend yields Neil - the
yields on some of these stocks the the
boards of these companies are making
good fiduciary decisions for their
shareholders and think about this when
you buy back a stock what happens
someone sells you the stock that person
then pays tax on that gain and that
person reallocates the capital to
another business that needs the cap
so the stock market is acting just as it
should in reallocating capital to those
businesses that need capital but the
promise that was made for the tax cut is
that the wages would go up faster first
and then it wouldn't go into stock
buybacks and plants and all that there
would be more going into wages that
hasn't so much happened some wages are
up but there's been eaten away by a
little inflation but let me ask you
about the the future we had look I don't
think that's right I think when you see
3.1 percent wage growth against 2
percent inflation
we've got 1.1 percent real wage growth
for the prior 10 years before the tax
reform was done we had zero wage growth
so we've had real wage growth in the
United States for the last year you
cannot deny that but you also had
tariffs you also have tariffs which are
attacks as you agree I agree
they are consumption tax so you have a
tax on these kind of workers a lot of
them buying Chinese goods that are now
more expensive there are farmers who are
having to get bailed out now for the
second time by the US government so you
have a policy here where you have
tariffs then you have a bailout to fix
the problems happening with the tariffs
so my question is in the future if
that's the situation with that we also
have deficit and debt numbers yes that
have gone up considerably revenue is up
after this tax cut but it's not up at
the rate that it would be under previous
policy so those are big long-term
problems for the economy look I'm not
gonna sit here and deny that we've got a
debt problem I think we've got a huge
debt problem and I'll be the first to
tell you that what our debt problem is
not a revenue problem is you just said
our revenue was up this year even with a
new tax tax legislation we have a
spending problem in this country but
that would have been higher under
previous point it may it may have been
higher you don't know that you don't
know that you know the interesting thing
is you say the revenue would have been
higher we don't know if the if the 500
plus companies that went out and gave
bonuses to their workers the weeks after
the tax plan was enacted we don't know
if those bonuses would have been given
we don't know if some of those pensions
would have been funded we don't know if
some of the companies that raised wages
right after the tax plan if they would
have been raised or not so you we say it
would have been higher we don't know
that what we do know is the economy
right now because of the tax point is
very strong and we continue to grow we
also do know and I agree completely we
have a huge debt and deficit problem in
the United States and we have to figure
that out and we just can't keep
bending a deficit financed this country
the president has said he will shut down
the government if he doesn't get the
funding for his border wall do you much
do you think that will hurt the economy
and how much will it hurt investors
confidence is that a good move in your
opinion first if you know never want to
see the government shut down shutting
the government down shutting a business
down is never a good move I'm I'm
hopeful that the Congress can get
together in the next couple days here
and deliver something to the president
that makes sense that he's willing to
sign do you have any regrets about your
time in the Trump White House absolutely
not it's the most amazing experience in
my life anyone who gets the opportunity
to serve this country they should take
that opportunity it was a spectacular
experience are you offended by the term
globalist which is what the president
called you I'm absolutely not offended
by the term globalist as I am ago it was
I believe we live in a globalized world
I think the United States is a very
integral part of a globalized world and
we have to figure out how to live as a
good citizen the globalizers so do the
Chinese so do the Russians so did the
Middle Eastern countries but we are
globalized we cannot change that back so
how many times Gary since you've left
have you said boy I wish I was back
there at the White House shocking to
believe but I'm really enjoying my time
on the White House my family in the
beginning was actually even enjoying
having me around and they're getting
sick of that but I'm very pleased with
what I'm doing right now it's good to
see you Gary great seeing you do you
need to be part of the conversation
thank you thanks for having me thank you